hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to the another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to talk about together
in this video is how to graph the
tangent graph and I'm hoping to make
this a lot more simplified for you
because a lot of students have trouble
with this particular graph they get the
sines and the cosines of a tangent can
be a little bit more challenging so
let's just look at the unit circle you
learn about the unit circle previously
and what we're going to be doing is
we're going to be looking at the values
from negative PI over 2 to positive PI
over 2 at negative PI over 2 the tangent
value is Y divided by X which is
negative 1 divided by 0 which is
undefined that's why we get a vertical
asymptote here at negative PI over 4
again tangents the Y value divided by
the x value anything divided by itself
is 1 but a negative divided by a
positive gives us negative 1 so you can
see we're down here at negative 1 and
then at 0 degrees 0 divided by 1 is 0
ok and then at 45 or PI over 4 the Y
divided by the X is 1 so you can see
we're right here at 1 and then over here
at PI over 2 1 divided by 0 the Y
divided by X again we're undefined
because we can't divide by 0 so we get
another vertical asymptote so this is
what we call our parent function okay
now one thing I just want to point out
is you notice that the period okay how
long it takes for this graph to repeat
from negative PI over 2 to positive PI
over 2 that's a distance of pi okay so
the period is PI I'll just write that
down here a period equals PI now let's
go take a look at some examples and I'll
show you how this works
so when you see this number here in
front of the x value of tangent 1/2 X we
can use the fact that the parent
function has a period of Pi and then
dividing that by this B value okay so a
period equals pi divided by B we get PI
divided by 1/2 which equals 2 pi ok so
what's actually happening we're not
actually dividing the x-values by 2 were
actually multiplying them by 2 it
actually has the opposite effect on the
graph but you can just use this formula
pi divided by the coefficient in front
of X ok that will give you your period
now this is one thing that I want to
mention to you is
when you go to graph this take that
period 2pi and cut it in half and the
reason is it because half the graph is
to the right of the y-axis and half to
the left so what you want to do even
though the period is 2pi is divide this
by two so that's going to be one pi and
over here this is going to be negative
one pi but that gives you a period of
2pi right so your asymptotes are going
to be right here okay just like in the
parent function and what I like to do is
find these halfway points these Midway
points so I would take PI and divide it
by two again so that gives you PI over 2
and negative PI over 2 and then all you
want to do is plot these key points so
we've got 1 0 and negative 1 and that's
our graph ok let's look at another
example here we have y equals 2 times
tangent of 4x so again we're gonna look
at the period it's pi divided by 4 okay
so we're going to do is we're going to
take that period PI over 4 we're gonna
cut it in half because half's on the
right side of the y axis halves on the
left so this is going to be over here at
PI over 8 and negative PI over 8
effectively giving us a period of PI
over 4 are you with me so far
okay so I'm going to draw in the
asymptotes I'm going to take that PI
over 8 I'm going to cut it in half again
so we're at PI over 16 and negative PI
over 16 but what's different about this
function is you see the two here the two
in front of the tangents going to
stretch the graph by two times so
instead of being at 1 we're gonna now be
out here at 2 instead of being at
negative 1 we're gonna be down here at
negative 2 so I'm taking these values
here and I'm multiplying by 2 its
stretching it vertically but 0 times 2
is still 0 so it's still gonna cross
right through at the origin there and
there's the graph now another question
that students sometimes have is they get
a little bit Wiggly with this line here
and what you can do you can think about
when you graph this on this side of the
graph it's what they call concave up
it's like a c-shape up so it's curving
this way up like a C up and when on this
side of the graph it's concave down it's
like a c-shape down so what you can
sometimes do instead of just trying to
graph it like this is start from the
origin do that part like a c-shape down
and then on this side graph it like
this and graph of see shape up and
that'll give you a nice curve you can
also think of it as like y equals x
cubed if you're familiar with that graph
let's look at one last example and
that's this one here y equals tangent X
minus PI over four here you can see the
PI over four is actually going to pick
up the graph it's going to shift it
right PI over four if this was plus PI
over four it would be shifting it to the
left PI over four so it has the opposite
effect on the graph when you multiply or
divide that's going to be stretching or
compressing when you add or subtract
that's gonna be picking picking up and
shifting or translating okay so let me
just show you this one real quick and
then we'll wrap up this video but here
you can see the D value the number in
front of the ax is one so if we use our
formula pi divided by b pi divided by
one is just going to be pi but i'm going
to take that period and divide it in
half because half's on the right side of
the y axis halves on the left and then
i'm gonna divide it in half again that's
PI over 4 and negative PI over 4 and I'm
gonna draw on the asymptotes okay just
like we did in the previous examples and
then we're gonna draw in our key points
one zero and negative one and so our
graph looks like this right now the PI
over four is gonna pick everything up
even the asymptotes and shift it right
PI over 4 you can see the scales PI over
4 so it's just going to be one step to
the right notice also that the
asymptotes are gonna shift one step to
the right so now our new graph is going
to be like this ok there's a lot going
on here in this graph but you can see
everything's going to shift right one
steps like this so there's our new graph
so I hope this video helped you
understand how to graph tangents better
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other many videos and I look
forward to seeing you in the next video
I'll talk to you soon